salve
canzone bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
simi questo nuovo video sono pari che io
ti sto facendo la intro col telefono
perché volevo mostrarvi una cosa se noi
questo video andremo a testare il mio
computer da 8 miliardi a questa è la mia
bottiglia con c'entra niente voleva
appunto a testare la potenza di questo
di questo bimbo gigante che mi permette
di fare il mio lavoro ragazzi abbiamo
una 3090 dall'altro ci pensa un super
per tenerla su perché sotto il precisino
sulle cose ciò corrisponda quindi va beh
abbiamo un raffreddamento a liquido per
l'uomo dente abbiamo tutti pezzi
praticamente number one con un i nove
10850 abbiamo un sacco di pezzi
ho installato appunto tutti pezzi
insomma di prima categoria in totale
compresa appunto il face limitato sotto
il resto eccetera anche con un altro a
3.090 che si occupa solo di registrare
di mandare in streaming live e di
registrare la camera abbiamo comunque
nel complesso anche la parte 18 un setup
da circa 20 mila dollari meno e quindi
testiamo locati testiamo sta roba per
testare ragazzi tutto questo ambaradan
voglio provare flight simulator 2020 che
ha una grafica cioè che non esiste
praticamente la cosa ragazzi che mi
preme di più per raggiungere l'obiettivo
di oggi quindi stressare il pc al
massimo per vedere come si comporta
devono non solo mettere tutte le
impostazioni grafiche al massimo livello
di dettagli al massimo ragazzi non devo
solo fare questo ma devo anche caricare
la mappa che più di tutte si avvicina al
farne esplodere il computer che dovrebbe
essere teoricamente quali new york credo
ora i boys allora se map ci sta
approcciando anni ora c'è ancora nave da
crociera po eccessivo però voglio
provare a passare veloci simo no perché
qua mi deve renderizzare oltre che la
città ogni singolo grattacielo ogni
singola finestra praticamente cioè anche
la pista di casa mia a milano quindi
questo è il massimo proprio che puoi
tirar fuori dalla grafica di vediamo
cosa succede innanzitutto la nave da
crociera è molto bella anche la statua
della libertà ma sarà veramente pesanti
io adesso sento il calore uscire dalla
mia scheda grafica abbastanza pesante e
poi dopo dopo che abbiamo fatto questo
test vediamo quanto si è scaldata
effettivamente perché ci sarà la
temperatura in tempo reale sta carica
c'è comunque ragazzi o classico col
computer che avevo prima e compiuta che
avevo prima era incredibile io vi
assicuro che c'era una è già già era
difficile caricare tutta sta roba e non
la caricava perché comunque non c'è devo
tenere i settaggi un po tenuti bene già
era un computer forte questo o max a
tutto ma cosa vuol dire che sto anche
renderizzando in 2k cioè perché sto
facendo il massimo
più di questo non c'è niente
sostanzialmente quindi credo che sia il
massimo di lavoro che una scheda grafica
può fare c'è una piscina su un
grattacielo ok sta leggendo era che c'è
un caldo sulla mia scheda grafica posso
metterci un uovo in questo momento però
va bene finalmente non solo è pensare
questo è il massimo ragazzi veramente
più di così così don da new york
veramente cioè e camminare in mezzo alle
strade per avere una grafica migliore
non saranno in stallo l'aaron me ne
frega niente voglio solo testare la
qualità poi può andare anche in stallo
l'aereo ne frega un cazzo
possa atterrare anche a central park e
volendo non ha calato di un frame per
adesso è teoricamente tutto a posto e
sono molto proud di tutto questo e si
vede tutto nel dettaglio nella maniera
più incredibile deve uscire solo ad
atterrare non so dove
ma anche senza atterrare la testa un
test poi voglio solo switch a rivedere a
livello di temperature come sta messa
alla scheda ci ha mandati in stallo
all'avere sbatto altamente le balle
ragazzi va bene così nel senso che
otterrà sul fiume suo annuncio arrivo
forse ci arrivo forse ci arrivo forse ci
ha rinunciato rio shahriari voti la fa
il carrello da fra il carrello zio non
so come a cosa serve il cannello solo
atterrare sul fiume non sa niente però
va bene ok perfetto
per atterrare aiuto
perché non so come si toglie non so come
si tolga la manetta
aereo fra niente perfetta a temperatura
ragazzi siamo più o meno eccola qua 73
gradi però se l'è cavata egregiamente
contatterà che ce l'ho installato anche
sulle ssd e quindi abbiamo sfruttato il
nostro computer adesso possiamo giocare
è più miss per il resto della nostra
vita post ma prima ragazzi e gli faccio
un giro da qualche parte a questo punto
allora abbiamo la città proibita sotto
di noi non capisco perché sia così tanto
previta ma volevo sorvolare per bene la
città previta non si capisce
anche ho capito che mi capito tanto il
tasto a posto l'ho trovato ho trovato
sai quello arti dello spettacolo
arte povera ts scappare giro entra nella
città proibita tanto ormai questo la
gemini c'è scritto sulla terra voglio
andare molto più in basso anche se
effettivamente chissà chi studia
areonautica si mette le mani davanti
agli occhi per come cazzo tra cui la
prova niente ragazzi devo far vedere
alla pippo la città proibita ragazzini
al a pechino quanto bello da città
procure non sono ignoranti geografia non
sapevo che esistesse la città proibita a
pechino come mi sa dire la lor di questa
cosa non sono molto esperto sono molto
più japan dipendente quindi non sapevo
queste cose però bene veramente figo va
bene basta atterrare in autostrada tra
nuovo però prima di farlo voi ad avere i
palazzoni a questo qua è comunque molto
più manovrabile dell'altro cioè io adoro
questo cacchio di aereo è bellissimo
forse ci passa pure dritto dritto a onna
dove per forza piegarmi però proviamo
no non l'ho toccato non l'ho toccato non
l'ho toccato dai dai dai non avuto
cassette dei bastard a questo punto le
onlus angels my brother prima vedere se
riusciamo a fare qualcosa di lei anche
se ormai è lei a martina di meno tra
tutti su play simulator perché è lei ci
son stato 11 volte però se le avete
viste tutte 11 tra l'altro bloccate
tutte è quindi ragazzi anche oggi in
qualche modo siamo arrivati a los
angeles mi manca fare blog ea los
angeles ragazzi e la pelle prima o poi
ci devo tornare a fare un revival poi
già los angeles 2000 e ormai saranno non
lo so veramente tanti anni l'ultima
volta che sono andato sarà stato 2017 se
non erro è passata veramente un'eternità
ragazzi non mi ricordo neanche più
non male che non mi ricordo più ma
ricorda memoria perché ho visto un
miliardo di volte però come ricordo con
le sensazioni di calpestare la terra
americana
era veramente figo però andò in scena
dalla pressione e vi farò vedere un po
di cose comune laker madonna siamo
arrivati comunque rahat altro vediamo se
riesco a beccare il mio il mio palazzo
mi mio l'ho comprato comprato io perché
io ero era stava in un hotel che secondo
me ne scali beccarne in qualche modo
aspetta se non mi schianto magari ok
oddio era esattamente al centro di
downtown però ci stava la banca di
fianco esatto stop all'azione qua enorme
ok ok
l'hotel dove stavo io è questo qua
aspetta sinistra madonna come faccio a
raggiungerlo questo qua sulla sinistra
questo corso a sinistra dove sto
passando questo quando il suo vice la
superstrada questo qua questo se questo
in quanto la società era il mio appello
una volta era bellissimo cacchio
veramente figo raga comunque sto gioco è
fatto veramente bene ma questo lo
sapevamo già non aveva visto palazzo
tutto ok
madonna però non mi puoi far schiantare
quando ancora non ho toccato niente
forbici credere fammici credere non ce
l'ho schiantato ancora ma ogni volta è
l'impegno comunque ragazzi promosso il
computer questo era prezzi qe beh dovete
capire se il video è piaciuto ma sento
al 100 commento è un mi piace
iscrivetevi al canale fatemi sapere cosa
ne pensate se volete altri voli da come
ti faccio di temi in porta e noi come
sempre ci rivediamo ad un prossimo video
bella ragazzi
[Musica]